donc vos copains sur le bureau là-bas
oui c'est merci c'était la mauvaise
façon de commencer
c'était vraiment on recommence
s'il vous plaît vous restez
même si le but est que nous ayons des relations sexuelles
je ne suis pas une prostituée tu ne le fais pas
je dois me payer d'avance je n'ai rien contre les
prostituées mais il y a une différence dont nous
pouvons parler plus tard
c'est désolé l'autre chose est qu'il y a
une limite au nombre de séances que nous pouvons
avoir fait Laura a mentionné que quand vous l'avez
vue
je sais quelle que soit la limite  est 6 mais cela
nous donne beaucoup d'occasions d'
explorer donc je comprends que vous êtes capable d'
avoir une érection oui mais pas par
choix combien d'hommes là-bas ah qui
donneraient n'importe quoi pour une érection naturelle est-
ce votre place non c'est un ami  les
seuls meubles de chambre à coucher l'ont à ma place
et je suis amoureux, je me demandais peut-
être si j'achetais un futon, vous savez,
au cas où le besoin s'en ferait sentir, cela pourrait valoir la peine d'y
penser. J'ai l'espace.
bébé à la retraite  combien pensez-vous qu'un
bon coûterait pourrais-je prendre une profonde
respiration et lâcher prise ouais est-ce que je semble anxieux